draco so look man i loved you
on on my name that's what i tell
everybody who's not from here i say
draco's the hottest rapper blast is the
hottest singer you guys you guys
came together on his project on the
deluxe
um well yeah i'm gonna say right now i'm
gonna say right there's a couple of
[ __ ]
i would say right now until greedy
right now though yeah right now right
now blast got it right here
no i'm up right now blast i mean rodney
ain't dropped since then end of 2019
come on right now and of course if roddy
rich drops tomorrow
there's not even a conversation let's be
let's they're both incredible and blast
will get there
but i thought it was dope that y'all
came together just i feel
i felt like okay this this had to happen
was there a situation where you did one
for him and he did one for you
like y'all got more than one song uh i
just told him too
i just haven't idiot because i've been
so rested
you're supposed to do some more [ __ ] i
mean we already
did the other [ __ ] in the studio you
guys [ __ ]
that was on e4 yeah yeah yeah on the e42
short [ __ ] yeah
we just shot the video for that don't
forget it was like two three days well
you i feel like you got to get the blast
a blast hook on your [ __ ] man it'll be
crazy